monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
lundi c'était à poitiers les foudres de
jupiter se sont abattues sur les
parlementaires si j'ai bien compris le
président de la république
l'inflation normative c'est la faute au
parlement c'est donc mes chers collègues
notre faute votre faute puisque nous
avons le mauvais goût d'utiliser un
droit garanti par la constitution très
encadré le droit d'amendement
franchement monsieur le premier ministre
franchement il fallait oser il fait des
choses et quand on voit que la
multiplication
des ordonnances qui atteint un niveau
sans précédent depuis le début de la
vème république avec des ordonnances qui
sont de moins en moins soumise au
parlement pour leur ratification qui
multiplie les amendements de dernière
minute sans passer par le conseil d'état
sans étude d'impact parfois des
amendements qui pèse des milliards
d'euros et puis enfin qui complexifie à
l'envi l'action publique un seul exemple
nous venons d'enchaîner ici dans notre
assemblée de textes sur la justice très
bien et en même temps le président de
république ou à poitiers les états
généraux de la justice alors lundi je
sais vous n'étiez pas au côté du
président la république vous étiez aux
côtés du pape et je ne vais pas vous le
reprocher à monsieur le premier ministre
mais dites nous la déclaration de
poitiers la déclaration de poitiers
était ce de l'humour ou était une
diversion pour faire porter le chapeau
au pouvoir législatif en prenant à
témoin l'autorité judiciaire
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole et à
monsieur le premier ministre
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs cher
président
retailleau je reconnais là votre temps
on pourrait essayer de faire dire au
président de la république ce qu'il n'a
pas dit
et d'en tirer des enseignements
politiques erronées
non non attendez je pourrais d'ailleurs
je pourrais d'ailleurs ce président me
rasseoir en vous lisant l'extrait
pertinents écoutez bien nous avons
collectivement
contribuer à une inflation législative
nous avons collectivement contribuer à
une inflation législative mais ce
président c'est le jeu je le connais
tous ici
je commence à voir quelques heures de
vol ce président je vous citerai
peut-être même des rapports du sénat qui
disent qu'il y à une inflation
législative dans ce pays j'ai souvenir
quand j'étais étudiant du rapport du
conseil d'état qui parlait de la loi
bavarde et je n'ignore pas soyez en sûr
monsieur qaeda que la loi elle est votée
par le parlement et que le gouvernement
contribue à son édification y compris au
droit d'amendement
je sais parfaitement tout ça comme vous
vous l'avais dit à poitiers avec le
garde des sceaux le présent la
république a lancé les états généraux de
la justice sujet majeur
le juge bouche de la loi disait vous le
savez bien montesquieu et oui la loi est
devenue de plus en plus bavarde et je le
répète c'est une responsabilité
collective en effet le président de la
république vous avez parfaitement raison
a aussi cité le droit d'amendement tout
en me disant pardon encore de citer le
chef de l'état n'est ce pas qui est
évidemment un droit légitime du
parlement qui est évidemment évidemment
et le président de la république a
ajouté et j'en terminerai là parce que
pas simplement parce que je suis allé à
rome lundi monsieur présent mais je n'ai
pas le goût de la polémique inutile de
toute façon pour régler ces problèmes et
vous le savez aussi il faudrait une
révision constitutionnelle et le présent
la république a fait allusion et que je
sache une révision constitutionnelle ne
se fait pas sans le parlement je vous
remercie
monsieur le président on retailleau
le problème est la vérité c'est que je
crois que pour le président de la
république le souci c'est pas tellement
l'exercice du droit d'amendement que le
parlement lui même je pense que
malheureusement il a cédé à une
conception très auto-centrée de la vème
république
selon laquelle finalement pour que le
président de république soient grands le
parlement devrait être petit et voyez je
pense que ça ne grandit pas non plus la
démocratie parce que quand on met hors
jeu les mécanismes institutionnels
habituels notamment de contre-pouvoir et
bien il y à d'autres circuits d'autres
mécanismes qui se met justement en pl je
pense à la judiciarisation je pense
aussi à tous ces réseaux sociaux qui
sont comme une cour d'assises
gigantesque et je crois qu'à ce compte
là personne n'y gagne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]